[Music]
hey you guys it's me again
time for tomes of terror this week we're
going to be talking about a book
that i loved i had a [ __ ]
blast reading this book this is
horror store by grady hendricks
horror stur i don't know i don't speak
german or dutch or whatever
things with um louds grady hendrix is an
author that gets recommended a lot
uh around booktube and uh this is
actually the first book of his that i
have read
um i do have another one back there in
my pile that i will get to eventually
this one can i just say from a graphic
design standpoint
i love this look at this
because look it's like okay now it's
weird because i bought a used copy
off of ebay or amazon or something and
look it says this is an advanced
proof copy and like you're not you're
supposed to check like with the final
copy before you do reviews and stuff
it says not for resale so somebody
resold it so
um i'm going to prison i don't know
probably not
this book is designed to look like an
ikea catalog and even it's not just the
cover either which looks like the thing
it's like the same size as the ikea
catalog it's the same color scheme
but look look inside they have like all
these let me see if i can find one
because this one's
it's kind of it's used so it's kind of
like so it's like they have they have
stuff like this
and everything has like descriptions
of like the piece of furniture and it
gets like more and more [ __ ] up like
as the book goes on
but i thought this book this book is
hilarious and wonderful and i mean aside
from just the whole aesthetic of it the
whole gestalt of it because i love
books that are like graphic design that
have to do with their theme
so basically what this book is about is
there is um ikea does exist in the
universe of this book
but there is another store that's pretty
much ripping it off that's just like it
called
orsk and uh same as ikea it's like this
really big
like uh furniture store that has like
you know the same multi-tools the same
flat packing
and it has like all this kind of you
know quasi-weird like minimalist like
european
uh branding you know what i mean so they
have like all the furniture has like
these
like slightly ridiculous names and so
at the beginning there's uh we mostly
follow like the main character whose
name is amy
and she has worked at this orsk store
for
you know however long and she's kind of
like she's kind of like a working class
character is very poor she's trying to
like pay back student loans she lives
like i think she lives in a you know a
trailer parker she lives somewhere like
in kind of like a lower middle class
type of area
so she's basically just working this job
because
you know for the money and uh you know
and she's just trying to like make her
way in the world and this is the only
place around in uh
in this town where uh you can make any
decent money
so she's just kind of there for the job
now we pit her
against her manager whose name is basil
and basil is somebody that kind of
worked his way like up the
corporate ladder and is now like
managing this store and he is like super
he's a nice guy but he's like super
by the book you know what i mean and
he's like very he seems to have like
really bought into the whole like
corporate culture of orsk it's like you
know this is all our family and so he's
like always like
spouting stuff from the employee
handbook and all this i mean we've all
like everybody that's had these kind of
jobs
like knows somebody like this so so the
two of them are kind of at odds
uh you know she just wants to do her job
and like go home and not think about it
anymore and he's kind of like
at the beginning he's he's kind of after
her all the time and she's like
complaining because he's always
seems like he's always picking on her
but kind of as the little bit of the
characterization goes on you find out
that he's picking on her because he sees
potential in her you know what i mean
that she could go much farther in the
company
if she would just like apply herself and
like get an attitude adjustment and all
this other kind of stuff so there's like
kind of some conflict there that's kind
of the main conflict of the book
so you have these two main characters
and what ends up happening like some
kind of random strange things have been
happening around
this store um things like
um you know things just being moved
around or broken or
um very hilariously like one of the
sofas
this sofa here on the front which is
called a brooka and uh
someone has apparently pooped on it it
looks like like
and it's very funny how basil like
doesn't want to say that it's poop he'll
just say like there's a substance
on the brooka and they always call it
that they don't call it the sofa they
call it by its like proper name which
kind of cracked me up
so they think that someone has been
sneaking into the store at night um
and kind of breaking [ __ ] or is kind of
like you know squatting in there or
something
so basically basil you know the the
people from the corporate office are
gonna be there like on the
next day and he's like look we need to
do like an overnight stakeout in the
store and find out what the hell is
going on like find out who is coming in
here and doing all this stuff
so he ends up recruiting amy
and this other woman who works there is
a cashier who's like a kind of an older
like a middle-aged woman who's like you
know very
her name's ruth anne and she's very like
into this job she's very like friendly
she's very outgoing
i guess she's like kind of she's like a
single and you know she just has cats or
she's like a cat lady but she's like
really nice
and she's nice to everybody and she
considers everybody that works there
like her friends and family
and all the customers and stuff too now
the two of them get recruited they
weren't actually like the first
choice because basil initially wanted
like some of the big burlier dudes that
worked in the store like just in case
you know that somebody was somebody
dangerous like living in the store
but they all had some other [ __ ] to do
and so it ends up that
uh these two women are going to do this
overnight shift with basil
you know and he says he's going to give
him like extra money like under the
table and everything because he's like
look we want to get this all sorted out
like before corporate gets here
so that ends up happening so they do the
overnight shift
and then it turns out like some i don't
want to spoil too much about it because
i didn't really know i mean other than
the concept of ikea-like store
is sort of haunted that was kind of all
i knew
about this book and i was like that
sounds like a really funny concept so i
started reading it
so other things happen like other
characters come into play
you know things happen like just kind of
stranger and stranger and stranger like
as the night goes on
and eventually it gets to a point where
it's almost kind of like it goes in
almost a hellraiser kind of direction i
want to say it kind of reminded me of
a little bit of like clive barker now
the thing about this book is that
the weird thing is that i really liked
i mean i liked this whole entire book
like i said i loved this book i love the
design of it i loved the concept of it
i loved the characters like the um
dialogue which was like really funny
and it's almost like the first part of
the book where they're just like
[ __ ] around in the store and like
they just first gone into the night
shift and like a couple weird things
have happened but nothing
really you know crazy or anything yet
i almost liked the the first part of the
book better
just because i really enjoyed like the
interactions between the characters and
like you not
exactly knowing what was going on in the
store and like them having speculations
about it and just kind of walking around
and i mean i will say too that the way
that grady hendricks
describes this story i mean if you've
been in an ikea store you kind of like
know where he's coming from with it
but imagining being in an ikea store
that's like this massive place after
hours well there's like nobody around
and like most of the lights are out
and just you know them kind of walking
around the store like doing like looking
for
whoever this person or whatever it is
that's been causing all these
disturbances
i mean just the description of it is
really really creepy and it's like
really really
well done because you can kind of like
picture it in your head so
i really liked the first part of the
book and then
it's and it's funny it's like almost
like a horror comedy type of thing which
i guess that's kind of like mostly his
thing
like i said i have another one of his
books uh my best friend's exorcism
i have in the pile over there so i will
get to that one eventually as well
but so it's so it's very much like a
horror comedy at the beginning and then
it almost i don't want to say like it
takes a hard right into
like i said into clyde barker town
because there's still funny [ __ ] that
happens like in the end but it really
does
go ape [ __ ] i mean you know what i mean
it really goes in a crazy crazy
direction
having to do with what was on the site
of the store like before it was built
there like a long time ago
so it's almost kind of like a
traditional haunting
but not really it's more like a it's
more like a hell razor
type of thing which like i said i don't
want to spoil it too much because like i
said that i
really enjoyed um the the whole like
experience of reading this book and like
going
through it and reading all the little
[ __ ] like the little drawings of
all the furniture and like the
descriptions of like what color choices
they came in and [ __ ]
i mean a huge huge amount of work
was put into this book like thematically
so it would all like work as this one
package and like i said i love
that type of thing i love that type of
branding so i just thought that was so
fun so like i said the the the second
part of it is like way more
horror themed than the first part i mean
the first part is just very snarky very
funny
um you know and you get like all this
conflict between
amy's character who's kind of i mean
she's in her 20s she's like 24
and she's kind of like snarky and she
like i said she just wants to work here
to get money it's like she doesn't
really care about the whole
corporate [ __ ] it's like she'll do
her job but she's not worried about it
otherwise
she doesn't want to go above and beyond
and uh so there's like the conflict
between her and between basil
who's you know really wanting to get
ahead and he's really like very
corporate
and like i said his character is
actually very sympathetic like you can
see why somebody would be annoyed by him
but he doesn't come across as an
annoying character he comes across
as a good guy um and he does have like a
pass that they get into
you know kind of a reason why his
character is like that and why he's so
invested
in this company because this company has
been very good to him
and stuff like that so you have that and
then you have ruthanne who's kind of
just this sweet
um you know middle-aged kind of lady
who's kind of like the
arbiter between them i guess um even
though she kind of has to like nut up
later on and do some [ __ ]
but like i said as it goes on you do
kind of get attached to these characters
and then when it all goes to [ __ ] like
at the end and everything just gets like
the horror just goes like [ __ ] crazy
um you know bad [ __ ] does happen so so i
think it's good that the
first half the first half of the book is
like built up so well like the
characters are built up really well
because you actually do start to
care about them so like when bad [ __ ]
happens to them you're like oh no it's
like
such a bummer this book i would
unreservedly
recommend to anybody i mean it was just
super fun
it's it was one of those ones where it's
like i would read a few pages of it and
then i'd be like no i got to stop i got
other stuff to do and then i would keep
going back to
like every time like i'm working at my
computer and i had it kind of sitting in
front of me i kept
opening it like read a few more pages
like to see what was going to happen
but it's like like i said just the
interaction with the character is
hilarious
and it's like i didn't really know where
it was going and the fact that it just
like
went this [ __ ] crazy ass almost
inter-dimensional kind of direction
like i wasn't really expecting it i was
expecting more like a straight ahead
haunting kind of thing so i really
really liked that it
kind of surprised me in that and like i
said the whole design
of the book is just it's just delightful
and
i mean the fact that there's even like
uh there's even [ __ ] in there there's
like order forms like that looks like a
real like furniture order form
there's like just all of this [ __ ]
[ __ ] like it looks
really like an ikea catalog and i just
love love love that they did that
yeah i would definitely recommend this
like i said this is the first grady
hendrix book that i've read
but i have one more and you know if
they're all this good
and this funny and this well-written
then you know definitely i'll be reading
uh more of this guy's stuff because
you know this was just it was so fun and
it's like i definitely want to
read it again at some point so yeah i
would totally totally recommend it
called horror store
but yeah this came out in 2014 so
obviously i'm a little bit behind on
reading it but you know it's just like i
mean i mean look at this look at how
funny this is it's just like really
looks like
this whole like it's just the the effort
that they
went into like to make it look like this
is just i love it i love it you know
what i mean
check that [ __ ] out it's just so so
[ __ ] funny
so funny you know what i mean so yeah
definitely pick this one up if you like
horror comedy and if that sounds like
something that uh that you would be into
because i really really enjoyed it and
like i said we'll see more of grady
hendrix
in the future so uh i will see you guys
next week when we'll talk about another
book so bye